ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนิสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียน
ผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมครับวันนี้สบายดีค่ะครู
นิคสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีครับวันนี้
สวัสดีข้างนอกก็ให้ตัดแปรงมากเห็นแล้ว
อยากปอกไปทำอะไรข้างนอกไม่มีเลยค่ะพูดดิ
จะว่าของหญิงเนี่ยมองออกไปข้างนอกก็คือ
มืดนะเหมือนเหมือนๆฝนจะตกดูอากาศไม่ดีขอ
ขอ
ก็ต้องเติมตัวอยู่บ้านเน้อบายใจค่ะแต่ว่า
เดี๋ยวเราเขียนวันที่ก่อนแล้วกันนะคะครับ
ได้เนาะเองเห็นนะคะเห็นจะโอเคคุณอีกวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะค่ะวันนี้วัน
พุธครับค่า
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
22 ครับ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายนครับเดือนที่หาด
ปีพตอะไรคะที่พ.ต.ต.
2565 ขับ a ข้อ 2 อะไรคะปีคศ 2
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้นะครับ
ที่เมืองที่คุณนิคอยู่ในเวลา
8:00 นเช้าแปดนาทีครับ
8 โมง 8 นาทีตอนเช้านะคะแล้วที่ครูหญิง
อยู่ตอนนี้กี่โมงครับที่ครูหญิงอยู่อ่ะ 9
โมงค่ะ 9 โมง 8 ที่ 4 ก็เช้าเหมือนกันนะ
ก็อาจจะสายๆนะบ๊ายๆแล้วแต่ก็เป็นช่วงกลาง
วันอ้าวไม่ได้เป็นเวลากลางคืนน้องเป็นตอน
เมื่อรางวัลเหมือนกันนอน 8 คูณนี่บอกว่า
ที่บ้านของครูนี้เนี่ยอากาศดีอากาศดี
อากาศดีนี่เดี๋ยวให้ดูกายหากแบบ
งูลูกสาวแบบนี้แล้วนะ
ถึงห้องเช้านี้แดดแรงนะเนี่ยจริงๆแดดแรง
แบบนี้เกือบตั้งแต่ 06:00 นเช้าแล้วถ้า
ง่ายคือครั้งเลยหน้าร้อนที่นี่นะ
แดดจะขึ้นพระอาทิตย์ขึ้นไวมากแล้วทุก
ครั้งที่คุณนิดตื่นมาเนี่ยก็เธอเจอสาม
แล้วแน่ๆเลยก็ดูนาฬิกาบางทีเอ้า 6 โมงคือ
เราอ่ะตอนมาตั้งแต่ผมไม่ชินกับทิปอาทิตย์
นึงขึ้นเร็วแบบนี้อ่าใช่ๆน้องแบบคือบ้าน
เราอ่ะก็ประมาณ 6 โมง 6 โมงเช้าก็พระ
อาทิตย์ขึ้นนั่นแหละค่ะแต่มันแดดมันไม่
แรงใช่ไหมคะของดาวเนี่ยถือว่าที่ไทยอ่ะ
แดดจะจะเริ่มแรงในประมาณหลัง 8:00 นก็จำ
ได้อยู่คือตอนสมัยเรียนเด็กๆเคารพธงชาติ
ไงยืนหน้าเสาธง
8:00 น 8:00 นไม่อยากยืมเพราะร้อน
เออใช่ใช่ใครเราก็อากาศดีใช่ใช่ไหม
ใครนะไม่ดีนะที่ไทยไม่ดีแต่ที่เนี่ยอากาศ
ถึงด่านมันเยอะเนี่ยดาษแรงเนี่ยแต่ก็ก็
มันไม่เอามันไม่เอาเหมือนที่ที่ประเทศไทย
ที่ออกไปแล้วเหงือกก็บอกแล้วมันคือมัน
ร้อนแต่มันชื้นเพราะว่าออกไปข้างนอกแล้ว
ไม่เหงื่อออกทำอะไรมันก็จะแคะเบียบไปหมด
แต่เที่ยวใช่ที่เนี่ยเสืออากาศร้อนแต่มัน
ไม่เป็นแบบนั้นมันร้อนแห้งมันเหมือนจะดี
แต่มันก็ไม่ดีเท่าไหร่บางทีมันแห้งเกินไป
เราเราจะแสกพันไหมให้ทันและที่ 1 อันน่ะ
เราไม่รู้ว่าจะทำยังไงเพราะทาครีมและคน
ไทยจะทาครีมเวลาอากาศหนาวและอันนี้อากาศ
ร้อนถ้าทีมอ้ะมันก็เหนียว
ใช่แต่ก็โอเคแล้วก็อากาศดีแบบนี้คนอย่าง
ที่เนี่ยนะคนก็จะออกไปข้างนอกกันเยอะเป็น
ทำอะไรกันข้างนอกแบบไปทำ
บาบีคิวหรือไปเดินเล่นในสวนปิคนิคบางเขา
ก็จะออกไปตกปลานั่งเรือ
ไม่เหมือนบ้านเราเนาะถ้าแบบบ้านเราอากาศ
ร้อน
อยู่ที่บ้านนะคะเปิดแอร์แล้ว
ได้พอเห็นอากาศร้อนไม่ออกไม่ใจแต่ว่าคน
ที่นี่น้องคนอเมริกาเวลาอากาศร้อนเขาก็
ชอบไปตกปลาใช่ไหมเหมือนครูนี้บอกแต่ว่า
ผู้หญิงเคยเห็นแบบแม่ได้เคยเห็นจริงๆนะคะ
ก็เหมือนแบบดูดูในทีวีหรือว่าดูพวกนาง
อย่างเงี้ยเวลาฝรั่งออกไปตกปลาหรือว่าคน
ต่างชาติเนี่ยเขาจะพายเรือไปพายเรือออกไป
ที่แม่น้ำ
ใช่ไปตกปลาใช่ก็ก็มีที่นี้ที่คนไม่เคย
เห็นก็มีพายเรือหรือแบบขับเรือที่เป็น
นั่งได้หลายๆถ้าใช่ก็ขับออกไปแบบนั้นเลย
ครับไปตกปลาที่ทะเลไหมคะใช่ๆครับก็จะมี
ทะเลทะเลสาบด้วยหรือ
ทะเลใหญ่ๆทั่วไปพวกนั้น
ต่อเวลาที่เราไปตกปลาน้อมันก็ต้องมีแบบ
อันนี้ไม่ใช่ของของของคนไทยเรานะคะเออ
กูรูปในเครื่องเลยแบบนี้แหละใช่ไหมคะอัน
นี้จะเป็นทะเลสาบมั้ยให้ทะเลสาบทะเลสัตว์
ถ้าแบบที่อเมริกาแล้วแบบกูยังรู้สึกว่า
เคยเคยรู้จักทะเลสาบก็น่าจะเป็นทะเลสาบ
มิชิแกนไหมที่เราจะค่อนข้างใหญ่
เฮ้อทะเลสาบมิชิแกนถ้าจะไม่เพี้ยนเนี่ยก็
อยู่แถวๆที่คุณนิอยู่นั่นแหละมั้งเพราะ
ว่าผู้หญิงเคยแบบนั่งเครื่องบินนะคะเราจะ
ดูเมื่อไหร่เราจะผ่านโครขอจบที่ทะเลสาบ
มิชิแกนรู้สึกใหญ่มาก
ใช่ๆก็เลยรู้จักนะ
สมัยหาเวลาไปตกปลาเนี่ยก็จะมีเบ็ดอันนี้
เป็นเบ็ดตกปลาครับน่าจะแพงอยู่เหมือนกัน
เนาะขอดูข่าวดูจากอันนี้น่าจะรัดราคาแพง
เลยรุ่นนี้กะครูนิคอยู่ที่อเมริกาเคยออก
ไปตกปลาแบบนี้ไหมคะไม่เคยไม่เคยครับอยาก
นะอยากลองตกปลาแต่ว่ามันยังไม่มีเวลาออก
ไปหาปลาชายไม่รู้ไม่มีเวลาจริงๆหรือหาข้อ
อ้างปวดมันที่อีกครับประเทศ
เราเนี่ยชอบตกปลาไหม
พ่อปหรือเปล่าชอบไหมอ่ะคือจริงๆอยากลอง
แต่เรากลัวว่าเวลาตกปลาถ้าเราได้ปลาตัว
ใหญ่ถ้ามันดึงแล้วมันจะเหมือนเวลาหนังไว้
ล่ะก็ตกปลาตัวใหญ่ใช่มากแล้วมันเหมือนกับ
เหมือนเดิมเราอ่ะตกน้ำไปด้วยเนี้ยเออ
เพราะเราต้องแข็งแรงนะในการยกจะหมุนก็
หมุนใช่เราปลาใช่มันต้องหมุนแล้วบางที
หมุนแรงก็ไม่ได้เพราะว่าไอ้สายเขาเรียก
ว่าอะไรเป็นใส่เป็น n หรือเปล่าทำ
ตามแล้วผู้หญิงเปิดกลับไปให้ให้นะคะครับ
ได้เพราะว่าอันนี้เนาะใช่ไหมที่คนนี้ส่ง M
นะใช่
สายอันนี้แหละครับมันจะขาดนะถ้าเราดึงแรง
มากเกินไปโอ้ยมันแต่ว่าโหตกปลาก็ต้อง
เหมือนต้องเข้าใจใช่ไหมคะว่าทำยังไงไอ้
คือมันต้องเข้าใจว่าที่ที่คุณ x เคยได้
ยินมานะคือ n นแต่มันก็แข็งแรงแหละแต่ว่า
ถ้าเกิดเราได้ปลาตัวใหญ่แล้วมันหนักแล้ว
เหมือนกับมันสู้สู้เพราะว่ามันรู้แล้วว่า
มีคนมาจากที่เลิฟสู้ชายมันก็ดีนี่ยินแล้ว
คนบนเรือแล้วก็แบบมันต้องดื่มมันเหมือน
มันต้านกันมึงไอ้สายเนี่ยเป็นเนี่ยมันขาด
นายง่ายจะหนาวมันจะแข็งแรงนะคะแล้วก็ตรง
นี้เนาะน่าจะหมุนตรงนี้หรือเปล่าผู้หญิง
คิดว่านะคะน่าจะมีผลให้ n ชาย
รหัสตะวะถ้าตกปลาที่ไทยนะจริงๆที่ไทยก็มี
เบ็ดตกปลาแบบนี้นะคะมีเหมือนกันแต่ว่าตอน
ครูผู้หญิงเด็กๆอ่ะตอนเราเด็กๆเราก็ตกปลา
นะแต่ไม่ได้จะไปตกปลาที่ทะเลมันก็เหมือน
จะเราก็จะไปเดินหาเป็นเหมือนสระว่าสระน้ำ
แล้วไม่ใช่สระว่ายน้ำนะคะพี่ปิดเป็นอาบ
น้ำก็คือมีคนขุดคุณแล้วมันก็มีน้ำหรือว่า
แม่น้ำอย่างนี้ค่ะเราก็ไปตกปลาแต่เบ็ดตก
ปลาที่ไทยเหรอต่างจังหวัดอ่ะนะหน้ามันไม่
ได้เหมือนเป็ดของนักเรียนที่เราให้ดูมัน
เป็นยังไงครับคุณนี้เคยตกปลาที่ประเทศไทย
ไหมล่ะคะวันนี้ก็ไม่เคยตกปลาเลยนี่ไหนก็
ไม่เคยทำไมเคย
เมลินีเคยเห็นไหมคะเคยเห็นครับเคยเห็น
อ่อนนี้คือที่ตกปลาคือคุณนี้เคยเห็นแต่
ไม่รู้ว่าอะไร
ทรายอันนี้คือเบ็ดตกปลานี้อันนี้เป็นไม้
ใช่ไหมคะไม้อ่ะเนี้ยคือถ้าแถวบ้านผู้หญิง
เนี่ยมาเขาก็ทำจากไม้ไผ่อ่ะค่ะแบบมาทาง
นี้ก็ได้เนาะ
มันจะเป็นนักเรียนรู้จักต้นไผ่ไหมอ่ะอัน
ไหนที่มันจะเป็นต้นไม้ที่แบบเนาะใช่ค่ะ
เราก็จะมีใบออกมาใช่ไหมไม้ไผ่ไปเนี่ยทำ
จากไม้ไผ่เขาก็จะมาเหลาเหลาเหลาก็ส่วน
ใหญ่ก็จะเป็นผู้ชายนะคะผู้ชายเนี่ยคุณพ่อ
คุณปู่คุณตาอย่างนี้ค่ะเราก็จะถามแล้วก็
ของของนักเรียนเนี่ยตรงนี้มันจะเป็นคล้าย
ๆเส้นเอ็นสมัยเส้นเอ็นที่แบบดูแข็งแรง
ครับ
แต่ของไทยเรารู้สึกเขาจะใช้เหมือนเส้น
ด้ายอ่ะค่ะคือแบบนี้เป็นได้แต่ก็จะเป็น
ด้ายเส้นใหญ่ๆหน่อยอ่ะใหญ่ๆใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะมันเป็นเหมือนด้ายเส้นใหญ่ๆแล้วก็ตรง
นี้ก็จะเหมือนก็นี้เป็นเป็นเบ็ดหน่ะ
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงคิดว่ามีอีกรูปหนึ่งที่น่า
จะเห็นเห็นชัดๆนี่ๆ
เป็นแบบเห็นนั้นจะเห็นว่ามันจะเป็นเส้น
เอ็นน่ะมันจะเป็นเส้นด้ายใหญ่ๆใช่ค่ะ
เบนซ์โอ้นี่เนาะ
กูมันเวลาครึ่งอันตรายมากเลยนะคะเนี่ยถ้า
มันทิ้งโดนเราก็คือว่ะเจ็บมากเว้ย
เราต้องมันดูไม่ยาวเลยนะสายเอสเซ้นส์ได้
นะใช่ค่ะมันไม่ยาวมากคุณอีกมันไม่ได้ยาว
แบบไม่ได้ยาวขนาดนั้นน่ะค่ะมันดูสิก็
ประมาณนี้เองอ่ะนานแบบ
ประมาณให้เต็มที่ก็อาจจะน่าจะดูไม่ใช่ค่ะ
ทรายไม่ได้แม่ไม่ได้ยาวขนาดนั้นเราแต่ว่า
เวลาที่เราจะตกปลาเนี่ยเรามีเบ็ดแล้วใช่
ไหมอย่างคนอเมริกาตกปลามันก็ต้องมีเหยื่อ
ใช่มีเหยื่อด้วยจิใส่ไว้ทิเบตอ่ะเบ็ดเป็น
แบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะเขาก็จะที่ไทยเขาก็จะเอา
เหยื่อเนี่ยใส่ไว้ที่นี่แล้วก็เอาลงไปใน
น้ำไม่ใช่ป่ะ
ว่าจริงๆคุณเน็ตก็ไม่ไม่จำไม่ค่อยได้ว่า
ที่เนี่ยเหยื่อเขาอ่ะใช้เป็นเหยื่อจริง
หรือเหยื่อปลอม
เกือบรอมึงทีมันก็จะเป็นเหมือนเวลาเราดู
ในเพราะว่าละครหรือหนังฝรั่งมันจะมีเวลา
ตกปลาเขาก็จะเป็นเหยื่อปลอมที่เป็น
พลาสติกไม่รู้ว่าคุณยังไม่แน่ใจว่าเป็น
พลาสติกหรือเป็นอะไรแต่ไม่ใช่สัตว์จริงๆๆ
เธอมันเอาไปหลอกเพราะว่ามันน่าจะเอาไปใช้
ต่อได้เวลาฮู้ว่าปลามันมากินเหยื่อเราคน
อื่นไปมันก็โอเคเอาไปใช้ต่องาน
เพราะว่าหรือว่าบางครั้งผู้หญิงก็เคยเห็น
เหมือนมีเป็นกุ้งไหมกุ้งคือเล็กๆอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยอ่ะ
เพราะว่า
เหมือนเขาอันนี้ไม่รู้นะอันนี้แค่คุณนี้
คิดว่าถ้าเป็นใช้สัตว์ตัวจริงบ่อยก็อาจจะ
เปลืองตัวว่าบางทีพบปลามันฉลาดมันก็มีของ
กินเหล้าเห็นว่ามีเบ็ดอีกแล้วจะต้องโดนละ
หนึ่งก็เลยไปเป็นๆแล้วเอา
สัตว์ตัวเล็กๆที่อยู่ใน Base อะไปกินแล้ว
ก็ว่ายหนี้หรือเปล่าไม่ง้อเธอใช้ที่ไทย
บางครั้งก็มีนะปลาวันฉลาดอ่ะค่ะว่าคนไทย
เนี่ยอย่างตอนผู้หญิงเด็กๆเวลาเราไปตกปลา
เนี่ยเราจะใช้ไส้เดือน
อันนี้ไม่รู้มีใครกลัวหรือเปล่านะคะมัน
อาจจะออกแบบน่ากลัวนิดหน่อยนะนี่นี่
ไส้เดือนคือโตยาวซ้ายๆค่ะเนี่ยไส้เดือน
คือใส้เดือนแล้วอันนี้มีมีต้นไม้ใช่ไหมคะ
มีต้นไม้เนาะแล้วก็มีดินนะมันก็จะมีราด
ตรงนี้ไส้เดือนเนี่ยมันจะอยู่ตำในดินน่ะ
ค่ะตามรากในดินใช่ใต้ดินเนาะเราก็จะมี
เหมือนกับอ่ะจะมีเป็นจ่อบค่ะไปไปแน่ใจแบบ
เนี้ยอ้ะ
เป็นสอบแล้วก็ขวด
หาไส้เดือนขุดหาไส้เดือนหายตัวเนี่ยค่ะ
เพราะมันอยู่ในดินใช่ไหมพอได้เสร็จแล้ว
เนี่ยเราก็มาตัดตัดตัดให้มันเล็กๆให้มัน
สั้นๆมันที่แบบไส้เดือน 1 ตัวเนี่ยตัด
เป็นเหยื่อช้างเป็นเหยื่อได้ได้คือตกปลา
ได้หลายอันอ่ะใส่แล้วก็เสียบลงไปในเบ็ด
ใช่ไหมคะในเบ็ดตกปลา
เอาเอา
หรอกเอาไส้เดือนที่เราตัดแล้วอ่ะค่ะก็
เสียบลงไปที่นี่
ๆ
จับเล็กๆคืออย่างเราก็จะมีถุงพลาสติกอ่ะ
ถุงพลาสติกแล้วก็ในถุงเนี่ยเราก็จะมี
ไส้เดือนอยู่ในนี้ใส่
มาเลยนะฮะสายแล้วก็เวลาที่เราไปตกปลาแล้ว
ก็เด็กเอาก็ได้เพราะไส้เดือนมันนิ่มๆไม่
ต้องมีกรรไกรหรือว่ามีบี้ก็ได้เด็ดแล้วก็
เอาใส่เสี่ยงไว้ที่เบ็ดนานแล้วพอเราไปที่
3 ใช่ไหมคะมันเป็นน้ำแบบเนี้ยหา
ตรงนี้มันก็จะเป็นน้ำเนาะเรื่องนี้ขึ้น
น้ำนะคะน้ำตัวนี้เป็นดินเราก็จะเอาเบ็ดตก
ปลาเนี่ยเสียบเอาไว้
หื้อ
แล้วก็
เอาที่เป็นส่วนตรงนี้ค่ะครับ
ใส่ลงไป siri เราก็จะมีปลาให้เราก็จะมี
เบ็ดเนี่ยเสียบเสียบเสียบเสียบเสียงเอา
ไว้คือทีเดียวก็ได้สิทธิ์อันเลี้ยงช่วย
ยอดลงไปแล้วตรงตรงหางตรงนี้ค่ะต้องปลาย
ตรงเนี้ยมันจะเสียบเอาไว้ที่ดินตามปะไว้
ในดินคะแล้วเราก็ไปทำอะไรก็ได้ 1 ชั่วโมง
หรือคือนิยากถ้าเป็นเด็กอ่ะถ้าเป็นเด็ก
เราก็จะนั่งแล้วเราก็จะรอขึ้นเองอ่ะจะไม่
เสี่ยงเอาไว้ผู้หญิงก็จะถือถือเบ็ดแล้วก็
เวียนเวียนเด็ดเราเป็นเด็กเราก็จะนั่งรอ
ถ้าเบ็ดเดี๋ยวมันสั่นต้องแปลว่าปลามันกิน
เหยื่อแล้ว
โอเคเถิดแล้วพอได้ปลาแล้วครูหญิงทำอะไร
กับปลาครับเราก็จะมีเหมือนคล้ายๆป่ะเป็น
กระเป๋าเนาะขึ้นเป็นถังน้ำมาค่ะเป็นถัง
ก่อนสมมติราชรามัญกินเหยื่อแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
เบ็ดของเราเนี่ยมันสายแล้วเราก็จะเอาขึ้น
มาแล้วก็เอาปลาออกแล้วจะเอาไส้เดือนเนี่ย
ใส่ใหม่แล้วก็เหวี่ยงเบ็ดตกปลาใหม่อย่าง
เงี้ยแต่มันก็มีนะครูนิคที่แบบเราก็ถือ
อยู่อย่างเงี้ย 10 นาที E20 นาทีทางอยาก
กินเหยื่อเออใช่ใช่นิเคยเห็นเหมือนกัน
ครับที่เขานั่งรอกันนานมากแบบคือคุณนิจำ
ได้นะว่าเคยเห็นเวลาไปภูเก็ตใช่ตอนนั้นไป
ภูเก็ตแล้วก็ไปเดินกินข้าวเดินกินข้าวกับ
เพื่อนแล้วก็เดินไปดูสะพานแล้วก็ปิดยืน
ถ่ายรูปเล่นอะไรกันน่าจะใช้เวลามันครึ่ง
ชั่วโมงกลับมาคนเดิมที่เห็นตอนเดินไปยัง
นั่งอยู่ที่เดิม
เราใช่การตกปลาคือว่าถ้าคุณเนี่ยเป็นคน
ขี้เบื่อเบื่อๆๆไม่ชอบรอ
ไม่ได้นะคะเออใช่ให้แต่คุณนี้ก็สงสัยว่า
ถ้าพ่อตกปลาแล้วได้ปลาแล้วเนี่ยปกติเนี่ย
ก็ยังคุยหญิงเนี่ยได้ปลาแล้วเอาปลากลับ
บ้านไปกินหรือเอาปากได้ไปกิน
ก็เพราะว่าที่ครูนิครู้เนี่ยที่อย่างที่
อเมริกาเนี่ยเพื่อนๆของแฟนคุณอิ๊กนะเขาตก
ปลาเขาก็จะบอกว่าจริงๆปลาที่ตกเนี่ยส่วน
ใหญ่ก็แคบถ่ายรูปแล้วก็เอาโยนไปที่จะทำ
แบบหยิบแล้วก็แบบโอ้ฉันได้ปลาตัวใหญ่มาก
เลยนะ
ใช่ใช่แค่นั้นแล้วเหมือนกับเขาแค่อยากจะ
ได้เหมือนกับเพราะตกปลาแล้วก็ได้ปลาตัว
ที่เขาบอกว่ามันยังไงทะเลสาบเนี่ยจะมีปลา
ตัวนี้ที่ตกยากมากเขาก็จะไปตกเพื่อถ่าย
รูปวัดเคยทำได้เราก็ก็เอาปลาลงน้ำเหมือน
เดิมหน่อยเหมือนเดิมก็คือเหมือนคนที่นั่น
เขาตกปลาเป็นกีฬาไหมคะเป็นกี่เหลี่ยมเป็น
กีฬาๆจะไม่ได้ว่าจะไม่ใช่ตกปลาแล้วเอา
กลับมากินผมขอท่าที่ตอนผู้หญิงแบบเด็กๆ
อยู่ต่างจังหวัดน้องแบบไม่ได้ตกปลาแบบไป
ตกปลาเพื่อเป็นกีฬาอะนะคะคือตกปลาเพื่อหา
ปลามากินเออใช่
มั้ยคนนี้ก็เข้าใจนะว่าเพราะคนไทยเราจะ
รู้ไงว่าปลาในแม่น้ำมีปลาอะไรแล้วมันก็
กินได้
ชายค่ะแล้วก็แบบบางครั้งมันก็เราก็จะได้
ปลาไม่ได้ตัวใหญ่มากมันก็จะเป็นปลาแม่น้ำ
ที่แบบตัวเล็กๆขนาดนี้ค่ะหรือว่าใหญ่
หน่อยดิใช้ประมาณขนาดเนี้ยก็นั้นทำไมบาง
คนเขาถึงแบบมีเบ็ดเยอะๆเราก็เสียบแล้วก็
วางทิ้งเอาไว้แล้วก็รอแบบอาจจะไปสัก
ชั่วโมงสองชั่วโมงแล้วก็กลับมาดูว่าเบ็ด
อันไหนที่มีปลากินเหยื่อแล้วก็จะเสร็จ
แล้วก็เอาปลาไปทำอาหารกินซึ่งจริงๆก็
เหมือนคุณนิคที่คุณเคยเล่าเห็นที่ภูเก็ต
อ่ะคะบางครั้งเราเสียบเบ็ดเอาไว้สิพวกเรา
อาจจะได้ปลาแค่ 2 ตัวก็มีมือ
ใช่เขาว่าปลาบางตัวไม่ฉลาดนะคะมันกิน
เหยื่อเสร็จแล้วมันก็ไปมันรู้มันรู้อ่ะ
ห๊ะเหยื่อไอ้นี่มันยิ่งๆมันต้องไม่เหมือน
มันต้องแตกๆอ่ะอะไรใจค่ะนั่นแหละแต่ว่า
ตอนเวลาเราเป็นเด็กๆเราก็สรุปนะแต่ผู้
หญิงเนี่ยก็คือเวลาเด็กๆไปตกปลาไม่เคยได้
ปลาตกไม่ได้รอดจะไม่เข้าใจด้วยนะว่าตรง
ไหนมีปลาคือเขาก็จะดูนะว่าน้ำตรงนี้ถ้า
มันมีเหมือนกับคนผิวน้ำแล้วมันมีเหมือนมี
ออกซิเจนออกมาแต่น้ำมันจะเป็นเหมือนวงกลม
ๆเขาจะรู้ว่าอ่ะตรงนี้ลาเยอะอ๋อแต่ถ้าคุณ
ไปดูแล้วแบบน้ำมันนิ่งๆไม่มีอะไรเลยอ่ะ
เนี่ยอ่ะกล้าไม่มีชื่อเวลาเราเป็นเด็กเรา
ไม่เข้าใจนะคะว่าตรงไหนปลาเยอะตรงไหนปลา
ไม่มี
ใช่ได้นี่ราคาก็เราว่าจะคุยเรื่องการตก
ปลาเนาะครับ 2 ที่แล้วกับปลาที่อเมริกา
หรือว่าที่ไทยนะให้นักเรียนฟังนะคะคิดว่า
ปีนี้คุณนิคจะลองตกปลา
ถ้าทำไม่ยุ่ง
ก็ไปตกนะเราก็ถ่ายรูปให้ดูนะคะว่าคุยใกล้
ปลาตัวใหญ่แค่ไหน
ได้ๆครับเดี๋ยวจะใส่รูปอยู่โอเควันนี้ก็
หมดเวลาจ่ายเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ใน
วีดีโอหน้าได้ทำใจครับ ok ไว้เจอกันใหม่
ครับผู้หญิงชายสาสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ